il est 20h bonsoir à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce dimanche
nous reviendrons sur la disparition d'un
grand monsieur du cinéma le réalisateur
claude chabrol est mort aujourd'hui à
l'âge de 80 ans ses films son regard
aiguisé et parfois féroce sur la société
sans oublier son humour son goût pour la
bonne chère nous parlerons de tout cela
avec notre grand témoin ce soir isabelle
père dans l'actualité également
l'explosion d'un immeuble de plusieurs
étages à doué la nuit dernière
le bâtiment a été totalement soufflé
bilan quasi miraculeux deux blessés
graves
quinze personnes ont été sorties
indemnes des décombres ira ira pas
dominique strauss kahn fait l'objet de
toutes les interrogations en plein débat
sur les retraites
le directeur général du fmi reste
silencieux mais grimpe toujours dans les
sondages enquête ce soir sur les réseaux
qui prépare son hypothétique candidature
à la présidentielle suite et fin de
notre week-end spécial immobilier coup
de projecteur ce soir sur le rêve des
freins des français de devenir un jour
propriétaire
ils sont chaque année 500 milles à faire
construire leur maison
reportage à suivre un dimanche de sport
avec la reprise de la ligue 1 de
football défaite de bordeaux et toulouse
lyon piétine paris évite la crise une
nouvelle médaille aux championnats du
monde de judo ferrari et alonso font
rougir les tifosi à monza
et puis 74e bol d'or sur le circuit de
magny cours enfin nous retrouverons la
fin de ce journal l'acteur réalisateur
américain ben affleck qui est venu nous
présenter son dernier film lors de son
passage à paris
ça s'appelle star en vain ce thriller
sombre et efficace voilà pour les titres
de ce dimanche merci d'être avec nous on
commence donc par l'émotion suscitée par
la disparition de claude chabrol mort ce
matin à l'âge de 80 ans le réalisateur
imprimés de sa marque le cinéma français
tout au long de sa carrière il aimait
peindre les hommes les secrets de
famille la bourgeoisie tout cela avec un
oeil à regard grinçant mais aussi
touchant et drôle
il aimait la vie et la bonne chère nous
parlerons tout ça dans un instant avec
isabelle huppert mais tout d'abord le
parcours du cinéaste avec marie-jo juin
le cinéma français et anglais
l'un des derniers représentants de la
nouvelle vague a tiré sa révérence
voilà le genre de phrase qui aurait
aurait piqué claude chabrol ce qu'il
aurait aimé c'est qu'on évoque avant
tout sa joie de vivre
preuve par l'image sur ses nombreux
tournages à malicieux provocateur
jouisseur amoureux de ses acteurs un
fils de pharmacien devenue critique aux
cahiers du cinéma avec françois truffaut
il définit ce qu'est la nouvelle vague
je pense que le cinéma soit la mer les
films sont des bateaux alors il ya des
vieux bateaux des nouveaux bateaux des
jeunes capitaines des vieux capitaine
écossais quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya ben tu
te souviens comme c'était un brave type
et leurs questions comme fou à la façon
d'hitchcock qu'il vénère chabrol à paris
dans le beau serge son premier film le
début d'une carrière compulsive un film
par an plus de 60 ans 50 ans toujours
l'impression de sauver truc que je me
fais mais le tout le monde trouve que ça
ressemble libre et c'est peut-être parce
que la bourgeoisie de province et ses
scandales sont le fil rouge de son
oeuvre il et décortique comme dans
violette nozière avec une certaine
perversité
mais pour pouvoir l'exprimer cette
perversité je me suis aperçu qu'il
fallait que je tourne d'une manière un
peu perverse m'appelle dans la gadoue
couper en deux la bouche ouverte
chabrol et ses acteurs souvent amis
quand complices tels jean yanne ou
stéphane audran qui fut sa femme son
actrice fétiche ainsi qu'isabelle
huppert ici aux côtés de jacques dutronc
je tombais rue de chabrol accueillant de
jeunes talents le race m benoît magimel
ludivine sagnier
merci à gimont peu récompensé il se
réjouissait pourtant comme un enfant de
ces quelques prix hommage
en fait un homme simple travaillant
toujours en famille avec ses enfants et
sa femme depuis 30 ans aurore pas qui ça
script sur les plateaux sa devise ne
jamais se prendre au sérieux
moi je vais faire un peu comme toi pour
une année sabbatique à sont en effet
remédie dernier film est son credo
l'autodérision il aimait les comédiens
les comédiens mais à huit reprises
il appellera la même femme pour
l'accompagner dans son travail c'est
isabelle huppert
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce soir j'imagine que salopette évident
d'être là mais ce qu'est l'histoire
entre vous et lui déjà on a une histoire
extraordinaire une histoire et ce qui
m'a accompagné quasiment dès que j'ai
commencé à être extractrices il m'a il
m'a suivi
dès le début j'ai eu le sentiment ce
matin quand j'ai appris sa disparition
je me suis dit au fond la relation entre
claude chabrol et moi c'est une relation
filiale pas uniquement dans la vie mais
aussi c'est ce qui fonde notre relation
de metteur en scène et actrice
il me filmait un peu comme un père fils
meurent et son enfant avec avec
tolérance
un peu comme si on tournait autour d'une
manière très complète assez sensible à
une certaine neutralité qui le
proclamait aussi dans ses films de
chabrol c'était pas le cinéaste du
spectaculaire c'était y filmait des des
monstres il aimait bien
raconter les mécanismes qui faisaient
que parfois la société fabrique à ces
monstres mais il l'est mais avant tout
les antihéros s'était pas quelqu'un qui
aimait le romanesque spectaculaire il
vous appelez à chaque fois pour vous
dire léger quelque chose pour toi ça
vous est déjà arrivé luidia n'ont cette
fois ci je pourrais pas donc non ça mais
jamais jamais ça m'arrivera jamais plus
on va vous restez avec nous on va
feuilleter un petit peu la journée
comment tout cela s'est passé de
nombreuses réactions celle du président
de la république qui voyaient en lui un
balzac pour la finesse de sa peinture
sociale un maître de l'ironie
pour frédéric mitterrand on va
maintenant écouter à la fois les
anonymes les cinéphiles mais aussi la
famille du cinéma qui aujourd'hui
reconnaît qu'elle vient de perdre une
nouvelle fois après alain corneau un
grand nom du cinéma français allait
engager florence mavic et et marie cros
vous êtes voisins et à chaque fois qu'il
y avait une soirée du beaujolais
il était effectivement au coin de la rue
et c'est vrai que il aimait la ville et
melgven il met bien manger des mets les
fêtes
un peu fatigué mais bien pourquoi
toujours aussi bon conteur
leur père des enfants excellent
cuisinier goûteurs aussi fade
moi j'aimais bien ça lui fait quelque
chose parce que nous mais par sa peine
de prison
il a la bourgeoisie en prenant un petit
peu un coup il était bien bien ils
disaient mais ça m'a bien fait plaisir
vu que je suis française ça m'a fait
plaisir de les voir et ça m'a cassé les
pieds qu'il est mort il est issu du race
de cette bourgeoisie il est issu il
avait un regard très vif de
caricaturistes si vous voulez comme de
miers et donc il
il a amené au cinéma cette idée du très
stressant et rapide sur les personnages
quelqu'un de notre patrimoine culturel
c'est parti ils ont l'impression de
perdre un parent proche les gens aussi
mais peut surtout plus que moi encore
parce que ça les a moi je peut
l'analyser saillie il perdra un oncle un
oncle qu'il était agréable de voir le
dimanche avec lequel si on avait eu la
chance de manger c'était encore mieux
bien sûr je n'ai pas entendu ce matin
je voulais pas vous attrister façon
hulot a été mais là vous preniez au
dépourvu pour répondre mais franchement
il était aimé tout le monde il était
très très bon metteur en scène
alors isabelle huppert il avait une
vraie patte quand on regarde un chabrol
on reconnaît tout de suite cette pâte là
c'est la marque des grands cela aussi
oui mais il ya souvent des adjectifs qui
décrivait que chabrol dont il
s'accommodait très bien d'ailleurs
truculent ironique et moi la bonne chère
ça l'arrangé pas ce que ça mettait
finalement une certaine distance entre
lui et les autres ça lui permettait
aussi ne pas accéder à quelque chose de
probablement plus opaque
chez claude chabrol plus plus mystérieux
sinon plus douloureux peut-être sinon il
n'aurait pas fait l'oeuvre qu'il a faits
qui est quand même empreinte de souvent
de de profondeur tout le temps de une
certaine gravité parfois est en tous les
cas qui était moine oui d'un regard sur
le monde qu'il a affirmé tout au long de
son oeuvre
mais au fond ça l'arrangeait qu'on leur
en jeu ça de lui il avait un compte à
régler avec bourgeoisie en tout cas il
avait quelque chose et la dent dure
parfois ils avaient c'est une pinte un
peintre social c'est ce qu'on dit aussi
oui je sais pas s'il avait des comptes à
régler avec la bourgeoisie ou avec le
monde en général les hommes
oui c'était un humaniste pour moi que de
chabrol avant tout alors vous l'avez dit
autre facette de sa personnalité
l'amour des bonnes choses claude chabrol
connaissaient toujours la bonne adresse
la bonne table quel que soit le lieu de
son tournage un amoureux de la vie de la
bonne chère c'est ce que nous raconte
stéphanie perez regarder il avait l'art
de mitonner des tête à tête succulent
entre ses comédiens sûrement parce qu'il
prenait le même plaisir qu'à préparer
une bonne tête de cochon ou à déguster
un bon verre de vin parfait entre
copains c'est une bonne occasion de se
réunir et boire un truc on n'a pas
encore vu chabrol le cinéaste
gastronomes qui organisait ces tournages
en fonction des bonnes tables du coin
histoire de partager sa passion avec son
équipe sur choisit soigneusement
parvient toujours trois ou quatre trois
ou quatre villes possible ou que tout
village possible j'en choisis chez lui
où il ya il ya une bonne fourchette
c'est très agréable pour tout le monde
certains de ceux qui partageait son
amour de la bonne chère sont devenus ses
amis comme ce traiteur de saumur où il a
vécu il venait souvent magasin et puis
c'était la paire wars avec les gens je
veux dit devant quelques fréquentent nos
magasins se déformer d'âme parce qu'elle
trinque actuellement des airs à compter
de ce jour ces petites nagui l'anecdote
c'est des sabbats sous l'oeil friands de
sa caméra il a fait dîner ses comédiens
dans chacun de ses films
je nourris mes personnages disait-il
sinon il meurt cinquante années de
balade gourmande sur grand écran qui
l'avait récemment résumé dans un livre
de recettes
cependant les repères que les choses se
disent et je crois qu'on en moins quand
on a la bouche pleine bouche je sais que
ça paraît paradoxal mais c'est vrai je
vous jure qu'il est très difficile de
sortir un mensonge quand on est en train
de mastiquer quelque chose il disait
lui-même qu'il était un ogre et émettent
affirmé que se désintéresser de la
cuisine
ça se désintéresser de la vie par
exemple des dîners souvent oui souvent
normandie on apprend qu'elle soit
vraiment bien oui gourmandise mais
encore une fois c'était peut-être
parfois c'est impeut à mohamoud écran il
y avait bien sûr mais c'était aussi
gourmandise des relations humaines
tout simplement c'était un homme
profondément bon claude chabrol saissac
c s'inquiéter merci beaucoup d'être venu
ce soir nous parler de lui de vous bien
sûr de ce cinéaste hors norme ce soir
france 2 lui rend hommage et avec vous
justement juste après le journal pour
trouver à 20h35
l'ivresse du pouvoir dans l'actualité
également ce soir les images
impressionnantes de cette explosion la
nuit dernière d'un immeuble à doué
plusieurs étages soufflé je vous le
disais et une vingtaine de logements
détruits
alors que s'est-il passé éléments de
réponse maria de masse et damien louvet
l'immeuble ne tient plus que sur ses
maigres piliers de béton et menacent de
s'effondrer à tout moment
le quartier s'est réveillé ce matin avec
l'impression d'avoir échappé au pire on
pensait que c'était une voiture qui sait
qu'ils étaient entrés a vraiment un
héros ou qui avait explosé
et puis en fait non on a entendu des
gens crier dans la rue a appelé les
secours vers ce court j'ai buté énorme
morceau de béton à m un maître de notre
lit quoi donc j'ai vite compris on m'a
plu j'ai crié j'ai hurlé qu'il fallait
sortir
l'explosion s'est produite vers 1h30 ce
matin au 2e étage de cet immeuble
les premiers secours ont été portés par
les habitants du quartier moi je suis
monté par la gouttière en fait par la
fenêtre parce que pour à l'entrée on
avait peur de rentrer
le bâtiment et mme boucher m'a soulevé
les gravats on a trouvé des personnes
les pompiers ont évacué deux personnes
très grièvement blessés et 12 autres
plus légèrement
la préfecture du nord estime qu'une
ouverture volontaire du gaz pourrait
être à l'origine de l'explosion et 20
familles sinistrées ont toutes pu être
relogés beaucoup d'émotion également ce
matin à marcq en baroeul où 2000
personnes se sont retrouvées pour une
marche blanche en hommage à natacha
mougel cette jeune femme de 29 ans
assassinée le 5 décembre septembre
dernier alors qu'elle était partie faire
son jogging je vous rappelle qu'un homme
de 39 ans déjà condamné pour viol est
passé aux aveux cette semaine après
avoir été interpellé frédéric crotales
natacha mougel était une passionnée de
course à pied c'est donc en courant tous
ensemble camille voisins et anonymes ont
voulu lui rendre hommage
cette jeune femme de 29 ans a été
assassiné dimanche dernier alors qu'elle
faisait son jogging sur ce parcours même
bien courir tous le dimanche donc on se
dit que n'aimerais pas que ça arrive à
quelqu'un de notre famille ou à des
enfants qu'on connaît pour moi cette
approche puisque
c'est un peu comme ma fille puisqu'elle
habite et l'habitant face
donc elle a gelé connu tout petit dans
la foule beaucoup d'émotion mais aussi
de la colère l'homme qui a reconnu le
crime avait déjà été condamné pour viol
et remis en liberté l'an passé cette
marche une grande mobilisation
une mobilisation humaine ya un je pense
des gens qui n'ont pas forcément conduit
natation comme moi mais qui savent
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin de se
mobiliser plus tôt ce qui s'est passé ne
se reproduisent une minute de silence à
la fin de la marche blanche en présence
de la famille de natacha demain auront
lieu à marcq en baroeul les obsèques de
la jeune femme auquel assisteront les
ministres la justice et de l'intérieur
cinq policiers municipaux ont été
blessés dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions hier dans deux incidents
distincts à aulnay sous bois mais
également à bové
trois d'entre eux ont été hospitalisés
des incidents qui interviennent alors
que le sénat à adopter cette semaine le
projet de loi du gouvernement sur la
sécurité
l'occasion ce soir de revenir sur le
travail spécifique de ces policiers
municipaux direction cergy pontoise
c'est le grand format de ce soir il est
signé sarah bernuchon et mourad bourré
team à l'affirmative vous avez eu un
appel en ce sens
talkie walkie à la main matraque à la
ceinture mais pour les policiers
municipaux de cergy pas d'armes à ce le
plus souvent possible à pied ils sont
surtout là pour être vu ça c'est le
passage principal entre le lycée et la
gare et relève donc fait pour éviter
qu'ils et les agressés au bien du racket
dans cette ville de 60 mille habitants
des quartiers parfois difficile c'est là
que les policiers vont au contact de la
population
ils font presque partie du décor en plus
c'est une mauvaise image assez souvent
là bon c'est la science agréable puis
c'est ainsi qu'ils ont c'est pas là bas
coût où les nationaux donc
parce qu'ils sont la petite pour
dissuader mais ils sont par mais tout ça
mais la meilleure arme de ses 72 hommes
en bleu c'est d'aller collecter les
informations comme aujourd'hui dans
cette maison de quartier un médiateur et
policiers se connaissent bien ils font
régulièrement le point sur la
délinquance ces particules en comptant
est de remonter de vol de véhicule le
week-end dernier
y'a pas ce côté répressif ya plus le
côté policiers de quartier ils les
jeunes peuvent discuter avec nous plus
facilement quand je pense qu'on aurait
des fois pas mal de soucis ont du moins
on n'évite pas mal de tension monte ici
perfectionnement tc monde ici en vingt
ans le nombre de policiers municipaux a
été multiplié par quatre plus que de
simples agents de circulation leurs
fonctions ne cesse de ces temps exemple
sur cette scène filmée par une caméra de
vidéosurveillance des vendeurs à la
sauvette de dvd sont pris en flagrant
délit est donc interpellé
de plus en plus ces agents prennent le
relais d'une police nationale en donc
d'effectifs août se retrouvent face des
trois quelques policiers m'ont se
retrouve face à une trentaine
d'individus que là on va passer en
maintien de l'ordre public alors que la
police municipale c'est pas les
prérogatives de la police municipale
mais face à cette situation elle obligée
d'intervenir mais jusqu'où peuvent-ils
remplacer les policiers nationaux à
cergy cinq agents ont été agressés cette
année de quoi susciter des inquiétudes
aujourd'hui on prend le travail on sait
très bien quels sont les risques mais
bon bah on essaie on voudrait bien qu'il
soit diminuer au maximum
donc être armé serait un plus un choix
qui revient au maire c'est à lui de
définir les pouvoirs de sa police atrg
aujourd'hui on communique volontiers sur
les chiffres de la délinquance
ils sont en baisse sensible depuis 15
ans c'est une circulaire du ministère de
l'intérieur datée du 5 août qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui au coeur de la
polémique une circulaire qui tend à
démontrer que les roms ont bel et bien
été explicitement visés par la politique
de démantèlement des camps illégaux cet
été après le rappel à l'ordre cette
semaine par le parlement européen
plusieurs associations et partis
politiques s'appuient donc sur cette
circulaire et envisage un recours devant
le conseil d'état
explication hakim abdel khaleq et
lorraine christophe lourd
la communauté rom visé noir sur blanc
par le ministère de l'intérieur sur
cette circulaire datée du 5 août signée
de la main du directeur de cabinet de
brice hortefeux il est demandé à tous
les préfets de s'engager dans une
démarche systématique de démantèlement
des camps illicites en priorité ceux de
roms
le terme revient une dizaine de fois
selon les juristes la circulaire est il
légal
cette circulaire est clairement illégal
puisque c'est une discrimination selon
gêne et nick ce qui est contraire à la
constitution française et aux
conventions internationales ne pourrait
y avoir à la fois un recours devant le
conseil d'état qui pourrait suspendre
cette circulaire il pourrait y avoir
aussi des plaintes au pénal contre
l'auteur de la circulaire pourtant ce
jeudi après un sévère rappel à l'ordre
du député européen
eric besson avait assuré dans un
communiqué que la france n'a pris aucune
mesure spécifique à l'encontre des roms
le ministère de l'intérieur et celui de
l'immigration n'ont pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions
une autre circulaire demande également
aux préfets d'informer la place beauvau
de toute opération d'évacuation
susceptibles de donner lieu à un écho
médiatique
c'est immoral et qu'en plus on veut en
faire une opération de communication
ça dépasse tout ce que l'on pouvait
connaître là jusqu'à récemment dans la
conception de la république
enfin il est demandé à chaque préfet une
opération par semaine au minimum depuis
fin juillet plus d'un millier de roms
ont été reconduits à la frontière
politique toujours et cette semaine on a
entendu presque tous les grands leaders
du parti socialiste sur la réforme des
retraites tous sauf un
dominique strauss kahn le patron du fmi
est toujours absent de la scène
politique française et certains
souhaiteraient que tout cela ne dure pas
éternellement ou en tout cas qu'il fasse
connaître ses ambitions parmi eux julien
dray invité ce midi de 13h15 le dimanche
on écoute si pas évident d'abord qu'ils
se décident ses loyers du vide ans qui
viennent il faut se méfier vous savez
aujourd'hui les silencieux sont les plus
forts dans les sondages
oui remarqué ça - vous dites des choses
plus vous montez dans les sandales ans
effectivement qu'il faudra qu'ils
abandonnaient ils me disent ah du tout
ce qu'est ce qu'il a l'intention de
faire pas trop tard parce qu'il faudra
pas non plus construire une situation où
on a je dirais plus beaucoup de temps
pour dû choisir entre nous le meilleur
ou la meilleure et dominique strauss
kahn qui malgré ou peut-être aussi en
raison son silence demeure en tête des
sondages pour la future présidentielle
seulement qui ne dit mot ne consent pas
toujours voyons tout de même ce soir
quelles seraient les soutiens qui
pourrait conduire à une hypothétique
campagne
éléments de réponse avec jamie timbert
et david fossard y penser toujours n'en
parler jamais surtout pas de guerres de
chapelles au sein du ps
les amis nous sommes pourtant bien dans
une église l'oratoire de la rochelle le
sermon et 10 par l'un des grands prêtres
de la religion strauss kahnienne pierre
moscovici des voix dsk prêt aussi à se
dévouer à être candidat lui même s'il
n'y va pas colitti du connu pendant que
le peut-être futur candidat
impassible dirige le fmi les amis comble
le vide et la tante et jean christophe
cambadélis ou jean marie le guen sorte
de canal historique au sein du ps de
grands élus comme gérard collomb chacun
y va de son pressentiment
et ce n'est pas toujours le même bah ils
nous laissent nous ses amis
martine aubry qui est son ami diriger le
parti socialiste et puis préparer
l'avenir
il n'y a plus de doute qu'il sera
candidat à jouer elle pense il ya
vraiment aujourd'hui une prise de
conscience très large et français d'une
part je rejette sarkozy sur l'aspiration
un candidat de la gauche et tout
particulièrement vis-à-vis de dominique
strauss kahn ça veut dire qu'il sera
candidat ou pas du tout et puis il ya le
club dsk
une toute petite organisation surgit cet
été en marge du ps est dirigée par un
ancien du modem pour les 18 mois les
présidentielles il est temps de
s'organiser
ça ne veut pas dire que dominique
strauss kahn pourra nous donner une
réponse immédiatement
le club dsk n'a reçu aucune homologation
officiel depuis quelques jours
d'ailleurs il ne répond même plus au
téléphone
en vérité rien ne doit filtrer n'ya
washingtonia paris derrière les murs
hermétique de la banque mondiale siège
européen du fmi ou une petite équipe
travaille certes mais uniquement pour
l'institution seul réseau actif
discrètement la communication ramzi
khiroun à gauche sur l'image
aujourd'hui engagé avec arnaud lagardère
il reste l'homme de confiance de dsk
prêts à se déployer le jour de la
décision sera prise mais ce jour semble
encore loin 06 d'autres j'ai une mission
à remplir je la remplis et je ne demande
qu'une chose c'est qu'on me laisse
travailler
le calendrier tardif du ps des primaires
pas avant un an a été fait sur mesure
pour dsk mais le temps passe vite
il en reste de moins en moins pour
laisser planer le doute entre le fmi et
la présidentielle affaire à suivre il
est 20h21 à suivre dans un instant suite
et fin de notre week-end spécial
immobilier avec ceux sur le rêve des
français de faire un jour construire
leur maison devenir enfin propriétaire
un dimanche de sport avec la reprise de
la ligue 1 lyon piétine toujours
bordeaux et toulouse chute
tony estanguet est redevenu champion du
monde de canoë kayak et vous le verrez
une ferrari brille en italien enfin nous
retrouvons ben affleck l'acteur et
réalisateur américain de passage à paris
venu nouveau en visite en interview à la
fin de ce journal mais avant cela
57% des français sont aujourd'hui
propriétaires de leur logement
l'objectif du gouvernement est
d'atteindre les 60 6% le plus rapidement
possible pour cela plusieurs outils
l'aide personnelle au logement ou encore
le prêt à taux zéro
de propriété de construction de sa
maison qui a cependant toujours un prix
au portage romuald bonnan et fabien
delory un petit tour de clé pour enfin
entrer dans un logement dont on est
propriétaire le rêve de la majorité des
français qui suivent dans la maison d'un
client en fait j'ai plus personnalisé à
son goût dans ce lotissement près de
rennes
le projet commence par une journée
portes ouvertes pour cette dizaine de
couples présents une nouvelle aventure
on a une situation stable a donc dû
convention c'est pour faire notre petit
chez nous et puis comment c'est notre
petite vie le fait de s'approprier aussi
un chez soi en fait de l'aménager à son
goût et voilà les candidats pour
lesquels avoir son propre toit est aussi
une affaire de raison d'un envie de le
loyer qu'on donne soit pour nous et pas
forcément pour pour 1
provocation et autres nous puissions
perspectives d'avenir mon frère
personnes jeunes pour avoir le temps
après 2,1 pas que franchissent chaque
année 250 mille foyers français le
portrait robot de ce gros marché ce sont
des jeunes 30 ans qui ont une barrière
psychologique qui est de 1000 euros en
remboursement mensuel pour leur maison
c'est ça c'est gros marché c'est le cas
de linda housni dans six mois son raid
sera sorti de terre mais ce sera une
maison d'architecte au prix d'un billet
en lotissement pour cette maison qui va
faire environ 140 mètres carrés
on est sur du hors taxes à 140 milles
euros en dix ans les prix de
l'immobilier ont flambé mais depuis la
crise les professionnels ont dû
s'adapter pour convaincre le client
je fais partie d'une génération des
gamins de la crise un petit peu les
architectes qui ont appris à dessiner
construire
imaginez avec peu de moyens le coup au
plus juste en fonction des envies des
clients un toit très cher aux français
c'est aujourd'hui la première dépense
des foyers voilà pour notre page
week-end spécial immobilier que vous
avez péché dans toutes nos éditions j'en
profite pour remercier pour vos
questions et pour le chat que nous avons
réalisée en direct hier sur france 2
point fr des images à celle de la grotte
de lascaux un lieu extrêmement protégé
depuis des années car menacée par des
champignons direction montignac en
dordogne où le président de la
république accompagné de son épouse a pu
visiter ce midi le site inscrit au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité
et ce à l'occasion du 70
vers sert de sa découverte chaque année
près de 200 mille personnes visitent la
reproduction de la grotte de lascaux un
dimanche de sport avec beaucoup de
choses ce soir des médailles d'or et de
bronze rallye de la formule 1 et le bol
d'or à magny cours et puis le football
avec la ligue 1 qui faisait son grand
retour ce week-end pas de changement
bordeaux et lyon font grise mine
pour tout cela il fallait le talent de
christophe duchiron de sa pagaie tony
estanguet transforme tout ce qu'il
touche en or cet après midi à tacen en
slovénie en canoë monoplace
il a remporté à 32 ans le troisième
titre mondial de sa carrière
en plus il a été deux fois champion
olympique au final ça lui fait un
palmarès colossal
la conduite en gants blancs est un signe
de grande finesse
à part ça sur le circuit de monza en
italie l'espagnol alonso l'a emporté sur
ferrari à la vitesse moyenne de 240
kilomètres heure devant l'anglais button
et le brésilien massa
ils ont fêté au champagne ce dimanche de
retour de week-end sans bouchon
aujourd'hui les fous du volant était
partout dans le monde
le français sébastien ogier et son
copilote julien ingrassia se sont
imposés au rallye du japon
ogier 26 ans gagne son deuxième rallye
cette saison et talonne désormais
sébastien loeb toujours leader au
championnat du monde
faut pas confondre au bol d'or et coup
de chance justement pour avoir évité la
chute et les pièges de la piste de magny
cours que le trio vincent philippe
guillaume dietrich et frédéric foray a
remporté la course sur une suzuki après
24 heures de moto l'heure était à
l'arrosage
a priori il n'y a aucun rapport entre un
ustensile de cuisine est une compétition
de judo
néanmoins c'est sur une moulinette
infligée par la juge à son adversaire
ouzbek que le français korval après une
belle médaille de bronze en moins de 66
kg la moulinette indique une attitude
passive est donc coupable du judoka
alors qu'en cuisine et l'aide à acheter
des aliments menu en ligue 1 nice a
battu bordeaux 2-1 en fin d'après midi
mounier bamogo ont marqué pour les rouge
et noir le bordelais modeste a réduit le
score sur penalty modeste le classement
de bordeaux 18e comme un grand cru des
classes et la page cinéma ce dimanche
soir avec la sortie du nouveau film de
ben affleck il est à la fois le metteur
en scène est l'acteur principal de the
town polars sont qui se déroule dans un
quartier de boston bonsoir ben affleck
merci d'être avec nous ce soir sur le
plateau tout d'abord est ce que l'acteur
s'est bien entendu avec le metteur en
scène
ils se sont bien entendu c'était une des
choses sur lesquelles je peux compter
sur ce fut avec tous ces culs acteurs
réalisateurs sont d'accord sur tout
alors pourquoi aviez vous envie de ce
rôle de ce personnage de jouets et de
l'interpréter le rôle et c'est génial je
n'avais pas eu l'occasion de devenir
réparé depuis longtemps c'était ça le
vrai challenge est restée close mais
vous avez quelqu'un le personnage sont
des choses qui sont répréhensibles
donc tout cela et pourtant on sympathise
avec le personnage à lorsque vous
adresser au monde sait que finalement
boston c'est la ville les braqueurs
s'est aussi caricaturale que cela y
attaquent les braqueurs c'est pas si 4
go il ya effectivement un quartier de
boston qui s'appelle
qui pour des raisons diverses et variées
cultiver un peu cette culture du
banditisme de deux vols à main armée du
braquage et c'est à boston vous avez
effectivement un nombre élevé de
cambriolage de banque par enjoignent 300
pas rentrer que l'argent est là pour
être pris on va regarder tout cela
justement on va regarder à quoi
ressemble ce tarn
je vous le disais un polar pas si
classique que ça regardez un braquage
dans une banque et la directrice prise
en otage
les gangsters la relâche mais elle en a
trop vu et représente une menace
l'un des malfrats va la rencontrer et il
en tombe amoureux je peux vous offrir
alors en tout cas je reconnais très loin
c'est une histoire compliquée parce que
le public en sait plus que le personnage
mac os il ne faut pas que j'ai l'air
trop naïve et c'était ça mon challenge
one s parvenir à un équilibre
le héros ben affleck est aussi l'auteur
et le réalisateur du chemin il a
rencontré d'anciens braqueurs visiter
des prisons et consulté le
haye pour donner de l'authenticité à
cette histoire elle se déroule dans un
quartier de boston qui détient le record
mondial des braquages de vrais policiers
ont conseillé les acteurs j'ai appris à
manier les armes à faire des explosions
c'était amusant mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir comment un
film efficace et a le temps à deux
niveaux loin de moi ouais l'histoire
d'amour entre deux personnages que tout
oppose et une traque infernale entre la
police et le gang ici ou de l'autre côté
alors c'est un polar dans lequel vous
vous casser les codes vous décrivez
l'histoire d'un clan de blancs
américains pauvres déjà ça casse les
codes de la délinquance noire américaine
c'est déjà un choix personnel
effectivement c'est un chemin que vous
soulevez c'est qu'en général on ne voit
pas dans les teams cette notion de la
pauvreté blanche amèrement effectivement
ce soleil aux américains qui sont qui
représente la pauvreté la fibre urbaine
alors qu'ici effectivement on a affaire
à une espèce de bon voisinage et ça se
rapproche de la réalité
un des aspects de cette histoire qui la
rend intéressante alors votre personnage
il est dans ce clan est un jour il veut
quitter ce clan il a envie de sortir de
ça et en quelques minutes dans votre
film s'est extrêmement bien réalisé on
se rend compte que toutes les portes se
ferment
il est aussi prisonnier que son père
l'ait finalement il est pas en prison
mais il est aussi prisonnier qu est
justement là c'est saint-etienne qui
m'intéressait choc le sud parce que en
fait les enfants et des proches et de
leurs parents est là l'enfant ce qu'on a
fait est assez difficile de changer de
vie c'était quand même un rôle qui
illustre assez bien cette vérité alors
raconté que c'est toujours aussi
difficile et une boire de plus en plus
difficile de vendre un film à hollywood
pour leur proposer pour convaincre les
producteurs vous leur avez dit que
c'était un film de braqueurs ça ça
répond aux codes classiques mais vous
avez réussi à apporter votre touche
personnelle votre papier déjà vraiment
une écriture
une patte ben affleck dans ce polar
faire un film qui reprend des gens et ce
classique effectivement le braquage de
banque mais ce que je sais faire c'est
de faire un film un peu de réflexion sur
des thèmes qui m'intéressent des
relations enfin parents le fait qu'il
est coincé dans sa vie qu'on peut pas en
changer facilement et c'est alors est ce
que comme vous dites expliqué dans le
film l'amour c'est la seule solution la
révolution
c'est en tout cas l'une des clés une des
meilleures voix que s'il faut se
racheter c'était la meilleure voie on
verra donc à la fois derrière et devant
la caméra dans les années à venir
digitimes certaines champigny mène sa
présence et adoucissant de la crise
financière défait de ses crise sur la
population américaine
je sais pas ce que je fais en tant que
réalisateur mais si on m'en donne la
possibilité
je serai au tour chez vous pour en
parler bonne chance d'un affleck merci
d'être passé sur le plateau de france 2
se tourne et est présenté au festival de
venise et il sort sur les écrans en
france mercredi prochain
à très bientôt et merci beaucoup
voilà pour cette interview réalisée
comme je vous le disais lors du passage
de l'acteur à paris avant de se quitter
je vous rappelle la principale
information de ce dimanche est la
disparition ce matin de claude chabrol
réalisateur s'est éteint à l'âge de 80
ans il était l'une des grandes figures
du cinéma français de nombreux hommages
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'émotion pour de
nombreux cinéphiles
on retrouve dans un instant sur france 2
et puis sachez que cela fait aujourd'hui
257 jours que nos confrères hervé
ghesquière et stéphane taponier ainsi
que leurs trois accompagnateurs sont
retenus en otage en afghanistan
voilà fin de ce journal merci à vous
pour votre fidélité tout au long du
week-end tout de suite la météo nathalie
rihouet 20h35
hommage donc à claude chabrol avec
l'ivresse du pouvoir et il avait lui
perd demain 13h élise lucet 20h david
pujadas passé une très belle soirée
l'info en continu et aussi sur france 2
point fr
m